I'm doing what you don't talk about some
jewellery later
what's up GQ does Elyon say and Whitney
on the rocks I got the name Ellie aunty
from young scooter we were in a studio
and he was just rapping and that's what
fit in the line and we just ran with
that should want to Elliott
my quality my work you know you could
spot my work compared to a lot of the
Jews work I redid a lot of people's
pieces they'll see somebody stuff is not
looking right over that measure just
wants to Elliott my first big client was
Nicki Minaj and made her Roman peace
that's when she dropped her album wrong
[Music]
future young thug 21 savage Chris Brown
little woozy
migos RTB little wayne birdman me pretty
much everybody was popular said this is
my new piece that actually recently
created it's the e that's on my heavy on
t it's a crown on top of it then I
actually had the stones cut the shape of
the crown and then I created a whole new
infinity link for it which people are
starting to buy it ain't cotton
honestly I don't even know what this
cost me because I'm using my own
diamonds you know I'm saying I just
didn't even calculate I'm about to sell
it though yeah it was he wants it he
wants to take the two E's out and put 16
over there
one of my favorite pieces I made was
take off solar system chain take off
chain there's a green light chain like
he just gives me the green light there's
no budget behind it really just tells me
to get creative and make a masterpiece
he didn't even see the piece till it was
ready and DJ mustard was the same thing
it was a greenlight piece I created him
to new Cubans with different style
thorns the ketchup bottle chasing the
monster bottle it's really detailed you
got to see in a person there's a lot of
pieces that didn't make it you not
trying to gather up as much as I could
from this weekend as everybody actually
was with so I took their stuff over here
that offsets nameplate piece this was
the first piece that I made with a
backplate everybody used to just do just
the letters or the numbers or whatever
so this was the first piece that I did
that way if and then I made my piece
same way but with bigger stones now this
is like a popular thing you know
everybody makes their pieces with back
plates this is like a worldwide piece
you guys seen this piece for sure this
trap house I made for offset with a
custom link it's a track basically
already hit me up and wanted to get him
a gift she gave it to him for
Valentine's Day he'd expected it was
like 275,000 door actually opens there's
two people inside bags of money there's
oven in there there's graffiti a lot of
detail to us well the chain idea
basically came from railroad tracks
behind the band oh this is a real place
I guess where they you know handle their
business that's why I had a lot of
meetings Sasa just to remind oh you know
where he came from
[Music]
next to this is just some emerald
diamond tennis change one carat each
used to be round diamonds everybody
wanted and now this is like a new wave
and rolled them they got like illusion
set but get changed as part of the two
these are three hundred each
yeah if you watch any one one three
hundred piece this is Metro woman's
piece this is another green light piece
he had no budget he just said make me a
crazy CEO loominatee piece that's what
it says woman I the CEO or emerald cut
diamonds each time in this set like a
break in the real pyramid and then you
got a five-carat blue marquise diamond
ji a certified 180 thousand he had a
different woman I be CEO piece but that
was for that time in his career so you
guys seen the other boom a 90 piece
previously but this is a new one a new
Metro since like 2013-14 making a really
long way I remember his first watch was
like two-tone Rolex it was like $8,000
and now he got probably like 1 million
dollars I'd say and watches and then
probably any got to talk about these
numbers when he got some stuff I think
is cool it's kind of yo we go to the
interview so gonna piece another
greenlight piece we originally started
with a different design and concept as I
was going along with the chain I just
got some more ideas he just told me
green light
yeah for sure any greenlight piece is
one of my favorite this chain like about
300,000 it was a lot of work like this
was all handmade this is not just a CAD
that was printed out so I got two snakes
on this side two snakes on this side
blue diamond about 1.5 carats
heart-shaped and then they got the
raindrops pair of shapes just dripping
down you know that's just a group of
drown honestly I don't even know I was
just chilling I was hi this is a camo
bracelet Chris Brown's he actually just
gates me to get clean so I got it right
here he started doing the camo on the
Miami Cuban link with yellow white blue
and pink so he got a whole necklace
matching with the base it was like about
50,000 and then he got a necklace it was
about 150 it takes a lot of time I only
had one specific diamond setter who
could actually do the camera so just one
bracelet alone takes him like a week
this is some new pieces that we're
finishing up right now this is for
future so basically this is like his
first original FBG piece that I ever
made him but we just made a little bit
more 3d and made him a little bigger his
artist about five total he got we made
all of them different he already has one
of them that's all white this one is
white and pink rose and white it's all
rose and then this one is Audioboo these
are about 35,000 a piece and then they
got Cuban chains with him to the back
says brothers for life and then at Leon
Kennedy the Marilyn Manson piece with a
Mickey Mouse hat and the 16 in the
center I didn't design this piece oszi
got that like in a beginning of his
career originally in a different jeweler
made it so he felt like he needed to get
all white one that one was black and
white I made them all a new one this
piece was about fifty five thousand I
made him actual little woozy a gun I
made him a shark tooth a bunch of Cuban
Linx I made a bunch of diamond chains I
made his upside down cross that's
actually getting rebuilt right now yeah
pretty much to the hostess stuff you got
a lot of new stuff on the way to this is
the high bridge pieces this is a bogeys
personal chain and this is QP chain QP
is one of the owners of the label this
one was about 115 this one was 15 so
this was made for Kodak black says
project baby me and I'm spoke about this
like when he first started popping out
they're talking about making a pacifier
a chain and then recently he called me
he was like well let's make that
pacifier chain but he wanted to like
with blue diamonds and white
I made this for cash he just called me a
few months before Coachella and he was
like yellow Coachella's coming up I need
some crazy was supposed to be a smaller
skull chain and then we ended up getting
a little carried away
we got a bracelet to match with it ring
this whole setup was like about 350 yeah
just a green light he found that at
Coachella how much it was it's crazy I
got a whole mechanism inside that's why
everything is working it's not flimsy or
anything
my clients sometimes call me because
they can't get the Cubans off because
have like you know actual mechanisms in
it like it has Springs inside the Cubans
I was a little lame last week and he
told me his Cubans the best chains to
jump around with because he knows I'm
not coming off let's talk about some
watches over here we got a rose gold
Patek 57:11 this guy is worth about
110,000 with no diamonds right now I
styled it going for like about 150
prices went up and a lot of these Haddix
bicha males the APS everything really
went up so many people bought them
already so there's not many around plane
and did discontinued a lot of them so
the values went up big-time
and this I start Richard Mille I just
iced one out for fun one day and future
bought it everybody started copying the
way we did his watch with the baguettes
on the side and the pave one the
cheapest one is a hundred thousand if
you could even find one right now for
that price but about 200,000 to 300,000
so what they're going for
this right here is stainless steel
skeleton this is one of the rarest a
piece the first watch I ever made like
this was 421 Savage he wanted to watch
that nobody had and nobody even dares I
saw one of these because just so
valuable we created a whole new setting
on his watch was the crushed honeycomb
setting it just went worldwide everybody
started doing the same setting right now
this watch is going for about ninety
five thousand playing with no diamonds
so the retail this is forty five
thousand then this is the same watch
just in rose gold also went up in value
it's about 100
20,000 right now playing then this is a
[ __ ] watch also skeleton rose gold
this watch post a lot of money it takes
a lot of time to make it
each stone has to get cut perfectly
there's no gaps in any of my watches
this is the paddock also very popular
watch is it going for like about 150
right now
same situation discontinued alright guys
I got to get back to work
thanks for checking out these pieces and
I'll be seeing you guys again
[Music]